Sigourney Weaver is one of the most
esteemed actors working today — and,
for her latest role, she's playing a blue
teenage alien who’s 59 years younger than her.
In creating the technicolor,
eye-popping world of Pandora,
James Cameron looked to a different sort of space
epic. In an interview with Variety, he said:
"If you look at how George Lucas did it
in the universe that he created, [...] he
chose to make each different biome, each
different culture, have their own planet
around the galaxy. And I thought, 'Well,
that's not the way Earth works.' I can
spend as many films as I want to make just on
Pandora, just by going to different places."
Cameron has begun to lift the curtain
on Pandora's cultural and biospheric
diversity in Avatar: The Way of Water.
With so many new shores to explore,
it stands to reason that The Way of
Water carries a few unanswered questions.
What is the fate of the forest-dwelling
Omaticaya people? What will happen to
the tulkun? Why did James Cameron cast a
septuagenarian to play a 14-year-old? Well,
apparently that last question has been a
particular point of contention among Avatar fans.
Sigourney Weaver made her first trip to Pandora in
2009's Avatar, in which she played
exobiologist Dr. Grace Augustine.
"I'm with her now, Jake. She's real."
Even though her character was killed,
Weaver nabbed an unlikely role in Avatar:
The Way of Water as Kiri, the 14-year-old
adopted daughter of Jake and Neytiri.
Kiri is one of the most important new characters
in the Avatar universe; the daughter of Dr.
Augustine, Kiri boasts a unique connection to
the environment and Eywa. Still, for some fans,
casting a now-73-year-old actress as a teenager
was a bridge too far. One Twitter user wrote:
"It really didn't work at all. The
movie is great but it was so jarring."
Some thought that the unconventional casting
choice was a missed opportunity to lean
into the themes of reincarnation. One person said:
"Sigourney Weaver playing Kiri was an
interesting idea and could lead to some
solid world building with reincarnation
and the world tree and the like,
but the performance...IDK...I could really
see this was an adult trying to play a child."
Others still felt that Weaver's performance
felt naturally less youthful when sharing scenes
with her younger cast mates, leading
her to stick out like a sore thumb.
While teenage Sigourney Weaver took
some viewers out of the action,
others were deeply impressed by the actresses'
commitment to the role. One Redditor asked:
"⁠Is it wrong for me to want to
see more young Sigourney Weaver
movies? She was awesome and killed it here."
One fan viewed Cameron's casting choice as
a win for older actors, especially women,
who are frequently overlooked. They wrote:
"I honestly love James Cameron for this. We
have accepted way too much ageism in Hollywood."
Weaver's performance also won over some critics.
For Consequence, Liz Shannon Miller wrote:
"Weaver's performance actually proves
to be one of the film's high points.
It's one of those 'damn, what can't she do?'
moments, watching her embody the character."
Ultimately, Weaver's greatest champion is James
Cameron himself. The director told Empire:
"Sigourney just became younger. She
looked younger, she had more energy,
and she never quite stepped out of Kiri
for our whole capture period. She had a
glow on her face and lightness
in her step and a fun spirit."